Man sah, dass sich sein Zustand verschlechterte,
und die Symptome zunahmen.
Am Ende dieser Kette hat er sich ins Auto gesetzt
und hat dieses Tötungsdelikt begangen.
Frank Urbaniok ist der einflussreichste
und wohl auch bekannteste
Gerichtspsychiater der Schweiz.
Wenn die Medien Fragen haben, liefert er Antworten.
Wir sprechen mit ihm über die
eindrücklichsten Fälle, mit denen er als
Gutachter zu tun hatte.
Im Jahr 2007 ist bei Emmen auf der Autobahn,
ein Fahrer in eine abgesperrte Zone,
in der sich Arbeiter befanden, gefahren.
Dabei hat er 4 Menschen getötet.
Der dreissigjährige Täter ist mit rund 90 km/h und
1,4 Promille Alkohol im Blut unterwegs.
Sein Verhalten auf der Unfallstelle befremdet.
Er ist agressiv und
findet geil, was er angerichtet hat.
Dieser Fall ist ein Beispiel dafür,
dass Menschen mit einer
schweren psychiatrischen Erkrankung,
die in der Psychiatrie behandelt werden,
dass leicht untergehen kann,
dass sie auch
gefährlich sein können.
Er hat seit vielen Jahren eine schizophrene Erkrankung.
Er fühlt sich bedroht, verfolgt und beleidigt.
Er denkt, dass auf ihn geschossen wird.
Es ist also ein Mensch, der sehr stark unter Druck stand.
Er war in einer psychiatrischen Behandlung.
Aus Misstrauen heraus hat
er die Medikamente abgesetzt.
Dadurch wurden die Symptome stärker,
und er hat angefangen Alkohol zu trinken.
Man konnte sehen, dass es schlechter wird,
und die Symptome zunehmen.
Am Ende dieser Kette hat er sich ins Auto gesetzt und hat dieses Tötungsdelikt begangen.
Der Täter war seit Jahren in
psychiatrischer Behandlung und offenbar gefährlich.
In den 70er Jahren hat man darauf hingewiesen,
dass psychiatrisch kranke Menschen nicht gefährlicher sind, als gesunde Menschen.
Das ist auch wichtig gewesen, weil es eine gesellschaftliche Tendenz gibt,
dass man psychiatrisch kranke Menschen
stigmatisiert und sagt:
«Die sind alle komisch oder gefährlich.»
Das stimmt so nicht.
Menschen mit psychiatrischen Diagnosen
sind in der Summe nicht gefährlicher,
als gesunde Menschen.
Jetzt kommt das Aber:
Unter psychiatrisch kranken Menschen,
gibt es ganz bestimmte, kleine Gruppen,
bei denen andere Merkmale zu der Diagnose dazukommen.
Die können dann hochgefährlich sein.
Dieses Bewusstsein ist bei den Psychiatern und Behandlungseinrichtungen,
lange Zeit nicht so präsent gewesen.
Es hat sich verbessert,
aber es ist immer noch
ein Punkt, den man optimieren kann.
Wenn man einen psychiatrisch kranken Menschen vor sich hat, ist man zu Recht fokussiert auf die Erkrankung,
die Behandlung und
die Therapie und dann übersieht man,
wenn es daneben ein Gefährlichkeits-Problem gibt.
Obwohl bekannt ist, dass er seine Medikamente absetzte,
wird es nicht der zuständigen Behörde gemeldet.
Mit fatalen Folgen: Vier Tote, fünf teils
schwer Verletzte.
Aus einer rein fachlichen Sicht, hätte man dort intervenieren können, auch müssen.
Aber man muss auf der anderen Seite sagen,
die Fachperson, die damals diesen Täter behandelt hat,
die hat so gehandelt, wie es tausend andere auch gemacht hätten.
Weil man als Fachperson in der Optik ist:
Es ist jetzt schon schwierig in der Therapie, nun setzt er noch die Medikamente ab,
was immer passieren kann, was tägliches Geschäft in der Behandlung von Schizophrenen ist.
Jetzt will man das Vertrauensverhältnis nicht noch zusätzlich gefährden,
indem man eine Meldung an die Behörden macht,
an das Strassenverkehrsamt.
Man muss auch sagen, dass der Therapeut rein juristisch nicht dazu verpflichtet ist.
Es ist eine persönliche Güterabwägung,
dies zu tun.
Aus seinem Bedürfnis heraus
das Vertrauensverhältnis nicht zu gefährden,
sich zu überlegen, wie kriege ich den Patienten wieder dazu,
dass er Medikamente nimmt.
Kann es dann passieren,
dass die Gefährlichkeit, die sich da aufbaut,
zu wenig in den Blick
genommen wird.
Wer in der Psychiatrie landet, der ist Patient.
Aber gewisse Patienten können zu Tätern werden.
Es ist lange Zeit gar nicht aussergewöhnlich gewesen,
jedes Jahr gab es Fälle, in denen bestimmte, schizophrene Menschen,
mit bestimmten Risikofaktoren,
die einen klaren Vorlauf hatten,
wo man sehen konnten, dass sich ihr Zustand verschlechterte,
dass die dann Tötungsdelikte begangen haben.
Weil man zu wenig auf der Rechnung hatte,
hier kann es sich auch um ein Problem
der Gefährlichkeit handeln, man muss das
abklären und muss entsprechend handeln.
Weil das in dieser Behandlungs-Optik
viele Jahre lang, viel zu wenig Platz hatte.
Aber woran erkennt ein Gutachter,
einen gefährlichen Schizophrenen?
Es ist immer eine Beurteilung vom Einzelfall, aber man kann generell sagen,
dass wenn Verfolgungsgedanken sehr
stark sind, man sich sehr stark unter Druck fühlt,
wenn dann vielleicht noch Alkohol und Drogen dazu kommen,
wenn es schon Drohungen in der Vergangenheit gegeben hat,
wenn man sieht, dass es eine aggressive Haltung gibt, in der es auch zu aggressiven Handlungen kommt.
Es gibt ein ganzes Inventar von Faktoren, an denen man sieht,
dass das kein «normaler» Schizophrener ist,
sondern einer,
wo die Risiken in den Vordergrund treten.
Das lässt sich dann daran abmessen.